we're just watching
those scenes uh the flags as they've
entered the grounds there
of the white house
president biden and the first lady
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
and there we have it joe biden
re-entering the white house after
a four-year absence but of course then
he was vice president now he
enters the grounds he's about to enter
as the 46 presidents of the united
states
of america
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
a moment there as the presidents and
their first lady
jill biden embrace the family
the large biden clan joining them
on the steps there as they turn
[Music]
and enter the white house to get down
to work uh maybe a few moments just to
drink it all in uh
and of course uh absorb what has been
left for them by the outgoing trump
administration they only left
a few hours ago of course there was none
of the niceties there were
no invitations as we saw with the obamas
four years ago when
when they left and they hosted before
they took over they hosted
the trumps in the white house none of
that
that is just tradition it's not
something that is mandated in the
american constitution and one imagines
that donald trump
would not necessarily have gone along
with that anyway donald trump himself
left a few hours earlier held his own
ceremony and then has flown off
to his resort in mar-a-lago in florida
no doubt
watching there on television